[Music]  the pigeon says to you  you got any bread  is it a question or what would i say  yeah my sentence back yeah would be  how long have you been able to  communicate with humans and can all of  you do it and the pigeon would say  no no  he said  yeah  but  can i we're intellectually above you  as are all other animals yeah so we  haven't brought ourselves to speak to  you because you're scum and your ivory  towers  you're obscure but i could really grow  some bread yeah how about that bread  have you got because we can't work out  how you make that  i will take do you want to know a little  bit of trivia about a pigeon huh they  eat dandruff  from off who well i was with my mate  right um  dandruff dave  [Music]  you're shining bright i'm your boy's the  baby you're my  [Music]